we'll take a bunch of suggestions i'll
come to smart side of the room first
uh just because you guys what would you
like to hear a rap about
underpants underpants do you have a do
you want to be you really let yourself
down smart side of the room
i was like we'll probably get some type
of quantum mechanics stuff from over
here
no underpants um let let's get a
specific type of underpants
what one so you oh you you said haines
oh well the specific bran
and you said tighty whities cool de
haines make tighty whities
wow a lot of women knew that just and
it's the only thing my man will wear
that's i have to say
tightly whitey's when you have a good
body tighty whities do look good um
unfortunately the only person i've seen
where tightly white is is my dad
and they do not look good um
i'm like they're cause i think it's
they're like xxl that he wears they're
not supposed to be tighty
whitey's they just are so
tight hanes tighty whities underpants
you guys
um let's let's raise the bar a little
bit
tesla nikolai tesla amazing that's
pretty
cool thank you for that nikolai tesla
i'm saying nikolai
is it nikolai or nicola
that you just answered with the sound i
was like oh he's hesitating just
ah let me think about that but you were
so confident no ah
it's it's uh whereas if he said i i'd be
like oh a scottish person agreeing
so haines tighty whitey's nicola tesla
i'm sorry i thought it was nikolai cause
nicola is a girl's name but that's okay
those crazy russians is he russian
which serbian wow nicolaita
tesla fans he's serbian are you guys
serbian you look like you could be
serbian
i feel like you've done some war crimes
you look
[Applause]
your sister-in-law wow is she here
she's done some war crimes wow
gosh i'm going to move on quickly
because a little radclone laddish down
here is chuckling away
um okay back of the room let's move on
from uh war criminals and
uh let's get a suggestion from you guys
one second what did you say monkey
torture monkey torture
okay okay haynes tighty white ease
nicola tesla monkey torture i'm sorry
that 7-eleven
i mean i know we'll take 7-eleven as
well that's fine we don't have that in
my country it's pretty cool
uh in my country that's just you know
the 7th of november
which uh because we do the days the
right way around guys
day month year that makes sense you guys
are like oh
month day year which makes no sense
you're the worst
not as bad as china china's the worst
they do year month day which makes no
sense like why is the year the first
thing you want to know
excuse me you got the date yeah it's dog
what why do i need to
know that so 7-eleven monkey torture
haynes tighty whitey's nicola tesla
um middle front of the room what would
you like a rap about north jakarta
[Laughter]
oh wow never has that been said with
such enthusiasm
um so uh north dakota is that uh is is
fargo in north dakota am i correct i
think that yeah okay cool
north dakota nice um it's so it's snowy
it's cold
what's their main export
oil what did you say someone said
something over there oil cool
we're now starting a debate about north
dakota i feel there was two very
specific camps there's
people who like nikola tesla people who
like north dakota and no
no meeting in the middle there okay
so the suggestions for one final time
haines tighty whitey's
7-eleven north dakota monkey torcher and
nicola tesla
this then is i'm going to stick all
those together to create a freestyle
wrap that is a wrap
made up on the spot should we drop that
beat um it's entirely improvised
entirely made up let's get a bit of
volume in it as well
and don't worry it won't be anywhere
near as atrociously bad as you're
expecting it to be
um you seem very unconvinced by this
don't you
just arms cross are you wearing like a
do-rag under your top
yeah just pulling a bandana out okay
that's
uh picking on a guy who don't deserve it
there we move on
nikola from serbia where these guys had
a bad time dropping down
war crimes let me talk about the science
in his mad mind
making all the coils transmitting
electric you can go to griffith park you
can spot
it got a tesla coil it will send it like
an arc light
it's so amazing yeah you could spark
life genius
inventor like einstein find his mind in
the past of his whole time
very smart really very clever i'm sorry
that i thought you were nikolai mr tesla
dropping that eye but not the iq
if you're hungry i don't advise you to
go to a place opposite of gourmet heaven
is hell taste bad when you eat 7-eleven
getting
all the hot dogs getting all the
chiquitos i try and buy them and then i
start to blow up my back passage
yeah always got the fear it's clear you
buy a day you will get diarrhea but it's
convenient i want some more it makes
sense nominatively convenience store you
can buy things
like chewing gum and doritos and
probably
hold up with a gun and take the money
and they'll give it to you they're like
that's all right
what you're gonna do i say flee before
reporters come and then i go
to the zoo and torture all the monkeys
and all the apes and the simians
i be getting electrodes i'm a silly man
i'm like a scientist
doing the experiments it's really hannah
hellish yeah not heaven sent
if i had a monkey right here i put his
fluffy ass on this sweet chair
and take a little axe to his kneecaps
chopping off his left shin in my relapse
in my kickback eyes roll back in his
face
i'm like this is for the planet of the
apes that's probably
how it started i don't know never seen
the movie so i can't just go
over there yeah my mind's so flighty
talk about my pants yeah tighty whitey's
not really
don't picture them in your mind if i
wore them this is probably
how i'd mind oh my testicles are so well
gripped they're made by hanes
so my balls don't slip they're staying
in place just like the frozen a tight
white grip
on a man's scrotum if it's right there
gonna keep the pubes in
so old wash them not in a museum some
people don't wash them
every day you could smell them coming
from a mile away
lady over there saying ooh why would you
say it
apologies after the monkey display it
should come as no surprise that i've got
exposed thighs because it cuts up front
we call them why
fronts in my country if i wore them now
it's in the front to see
i'm just feeling time cause i forgot the
last word
shout out remind me like a cheeky little
bird yeah a cold place so you know i
never go there never take a flight up to
north dakota i might go cause i like the
coen brothers
fargo south dakota they know it's above
us they export oil and they make a lot
of wealth but if you're there it's
probably bad for your health because the
only place to eat is a 7-eleven eye
or the food that tastes bad because it's
deep fried
[Applause]
[Music]
you